que les gens me voient bon cette fois ci
je me suis normalement un peu amélioré
je me suis renseigné et là on est
vraiment en horizontal on est plus en
vertical comme un boulot ce voilà donc
petit live et youtube avec mes potes et
qu'est ce qu'on fait en ce moment on est
en train de que staut et mon décor de
vidéos avec dunga
applaudissements sur les bancs de gains
énormes informée seulement en solo on
est aussi ric-rac ici présents et l'eau
totalement saluer tous très très beau
très très bel homme brun à l'air est
très attirant qui porte actuellement
ensuite en plus alors je tiens à dire
que c'est pas moi qui lui ai demandé de
porter sweet c'est vrai c'est lui qui
m'a dit si tu bouges mais ensuite le
bouton power
oui a pas non plus pendant 30 ans c'est
complètement vrai nom si si c'est
totalement vrai bon voilà donc l'idée
c'est de vous montrer un petit peu à
cette évolution
une sorte de fil rouge de la soirée et
moi j'ai envie d'un truc ce que par
commentaires dites moi un petit peu des
petits délires et nous on a incrusté un
de vos délires dans le décor voilà une
dédicace à l'inde et à des abonnés ou
voilà on en mettra un ou deux si vous
êtes chose c'est pas un truc trop chou
tel un sigles nazis on pourra attendre
que la crise était dedans
il n'y a pas dans le style de nazis
alors qu'est ce qu'on a comme qu'est ce
qu'on a comme motif
on a du canard aux tétons du 1 m
dérogeant aux tétons gênant gameboy
gameboy
voilà qui fait le signe power on à la
saucisse de strasbourg
voilà il s'y présente très bien fait ça
je découvrais un temps je n'aime pas
trop analyser ça je veux pas spoiler on
a le crayon cas c'est un petit peu le
sort de référence à la créativité
j'adore j'adore ce délire on a
évidemment un petit peu de côté hardcore
son côté j'adore la mort et puis et puis
du burger parce que ça fait plaisir
voilà donc c'est comme je les invite les
gens à les voir un peu le taf de mon
pote doug il fait à des graves par tous
comme ça dans dans le monde entier
moi qui sont affiliés à un tableur
d'ailleurs je préparais le petit à petit
site web le petit homme pleure à aller
visiter au klm
voilà que du taf de qualité que les tout
comme ça moi je suis très très femme
voilà donc douglas cavanna pointer leurs
points comme ça pas un coup de pub pour
les plus tôt ça fait plaisir et je suis
avec jeune rachid
voilà qui m'a dit cette fois je suis
vraiment à fond là rires je suis hyper à
fond dans le live et je prépare en même
temps ma nouvelle vidéo donc je vais
tourner dans ma chambre sans les hyènes
et montcuq sa caméra mais banon dans le
cylindre est pas la chambre pour que ce
soit propre et beau et con on peut
reconnaître que c'est la jambe avec deux
une chose effectivement ça aussi ça ça
veut dire t'es chez moi
voilà ça ça veut dire que chez moi et
deux il n'y a pas de doute c'est que
t'es chez moi et je prépare une petite
vidéo dans cette chambre que j'habite à
paris en colocation qui est aussi la
carte
voilà messieurs c'est complètement faux
c'est quand même assez agréable très moi
personnellement j'ai envie de me coucher
tellement seul il est agréable alors à
dix une place comme en classe verte avec
les poteaux c'est pas mal mais quand on
a 30 ans
mais bon ça fait plaisir quand tu es là
tu fermes avec vous d'accord d'accord
c'est que je peux vraiment courir
vraiment et à ckoi le thème de la
prochaine vidéo donc tu taf on pose la
question on en a pour son enseigne et le
thème de la prochaine vidéo mais qu'un
petit alors ce qui est bien quand tu
fais une vidéo ce qu'est ce qui est cool
c'est que tu coupes ici on connaît tous
on a le format ouest en est comme ça
d'accord donc en dessous je suis comment
as tu es en voilà c'est d'escroquerie
ont été très très attirant quand même à
très très belle jambe on coupe
pour moi c'est cool donc à part le
coiffe une vidéo ça parle de dé
d'émeutes en banlieue voilà on est sur
une thématique plutôt légère c'est pas
les gens comme toi tu est un mec engagé
bah ouais moi qui suis je
je fais pas des vidéos pour rien
j'essaie web assez clairement une leçon
que vient de donner une leçon de vidéos
youtube merci mon bateau et là on est
sur quoi on est sur un projet feu de
bois
du côté wallon guy un petit feu de bois
par an qui kiffe la vie en train de
smiley bon moi ce que je veux voir c'est
des gens qui a fondé propal pour
incruster l'un d'eux le de vous aider
dans vos murs c'est vraiment une volonté
j'ai envie que mon mur soit un peu
participatif 2.0 donc si vous avez des
idées je vais lire vos commentaires sur
twitter en direct et on va mettre l'un
de vos délires sur mon mur
alors cette fois ci je me suis un tout
petit peu préparé j'ai préparé ma page
twitter pour voir un petit peu vos
propositions qui pour l'instant sur ton
nombre de zéros on va pas aller très
très loin
ac c'est bon j'ai des propositions et ou
alors je ne sais pas peut-être que les
gens proposent sur le chat ici on a eu
un dauphin nous propose delfina est-ce
que c'est décidément un dauphin
ça peut se faire sans la première fois
ça fait ressembler à un autre animal on
sait pas ce truc un dauphin
on a une [ __ ] nous dit julien merci à
tous pour une biquette dessine un panda
donc tous les animaux quoi licorne
moi j'ai pensé le décor ni quand mais
moi je suis plutôt chaud pour une
licorne
voilà on met déjà une option là dessus
on met une option sur la licorne
alors n'hésitez pas à mettre un maximum
de pouce en l'air sur la vidéo vraiment
le plus possible j'en ai battre le
record de pouce en l'air de deux
milliards deux pouces en l'air c'est
impossible mais voilà n'hésitez pas à
mettre ça parce que ça fait toujours
plaisir voilà j'y pense maintenant
autant tout dire donc on a un mouton à
j'ai prévu de mettre un petit mouton
par ailleurs je montre je montre un peu
le décor des pas vraiment des vidéos
salut faux et donc a priori à un petit
mouton qui sera présent dans cette zone
surtout que ce n'est pas du tout ce
qu'ils m'en fallait déjà 200 moutons
dans le décor par le réal tente ici et
voilà une licorne avait dit que montrer
un petit faut peut-être pour garder un
petit peu l'esprit des vidéos ainsi pris
un shove ouais ça c'est vraiment je
disais tout vaut toutes vos propositions
ce serait vraiment un chat enfin une
vidéo - de 18 parce que c'est un record
bon c'est cool alors ici que j'en ai
profité pour faire un petit ménage de
monde parce que ce décor est également
c'est un petit détail est également mon
salon un non lieu de vie donc j'essaye
de faire en sorte que ce soit un peu
clean donc là je venais tous un petit
peu tout comme peut le voir une sorte de
poubelles gravissime chez moi et j'ai
récupéré pu rappeler les éléments qui
avaient dans le décor comme par exemple
ce petit nain qui m'a été offert par
blanche dédicaça blanche pas poteau 1-1
qui fait un fait quand on peut le dire
référence également pour les
connaisseurs un pin que j'ai doublé par
le doublé d'ailleurs là qui s'appelle
projet x voit là dedans il ya un petit
nain qui est l'emblème du film donc
ça fait plaisir on a quoi on a du mouton
évidemment du luigi
bon je vais j'ai essayé de gc d'évacuer
un petit peu les objets qui sont
vraiment est vraiment adapté à des gens
de 5 6 ans pour ce que je commence à
grandir
je vais avoir 30 ans et où il faut le
dire donc j'essaie de devenir un pro
sens plus mature mais on dirait pas
comme ça mais c'est quand même j'ai fait
l'effort
donc j'essaie de regarder quel meilleur
à temps il faut savoir que pour les
amateurs les abonnés aficionados de john
rachid tu as fait une vidéo qui
s'appelle karim assez la cage a plutôt
maquillage de karima que j'ai cadré
je tenais la caméra et je vous montre le
cadre que ça faisait ça faisait tu veux
tu peux nous refaire la scène un bien
ouej alors je peux dire comment très
bientôt même j'imite karman qui a cadré
alors il m'a vraiment aidé merci d'un
frérot il a vraiment fait ça regardez ça
ces écoutes c'est un minimum jeter le
talent j'ai pas besoin de plus moi il
faut juste cinq minutes voilà c'est tout
elle reste sur la vidéo est très bien
fait bien ouej aller la voir l'étude
tous de karim bon bref
oh là là on est sur une propal de la
part de doug on est sur un petit volcan
un petit volcan et tout ce qui est
chaleur ça brûle quoi voilà c'est pas un
bon chrono bmc un volcan vraiment de
l'enfer très très beau bon bah du coup
caisson place comme j'ai pas encore fait
m'a pris ma décision
je ferai un live de dix minutes ça fait
déjà huit faut vraiment que je me
dépêche buteur dont vous proposez quoi
comme comme petit motif a ajouté on peut
remettre paquin pour mettre 1 2 3 1 s'en
fout donc il y avait la licorne chaud le
dauphin très chaud peut-être sera la
forme d'un loup on sait pas je suis
québécois ok tristan attends tu me
prends et pourvus et à ce petit côté
blues dans ta voix ce petit côté qui me
rappelle les années sixties qui me donne
clairement envie de te faire l'amour
chant piano
voilà merci à tous c'était andré
manoukian et je sais également faire un
youtube heures tu le sais un oui le faut
pas aller je le fais la petite et deng
c'était thibault in shape peuvent vous
l'avez deviné voilà toujours raf qui est
en train de faire actuellement huit
textos en même temps exactement alors
rappelé que vous reconnaissez ou pas ce
mec très bien l'homme qui a joué nous
toutefois dans les vidéos ouais c'est
vrai combien de fois j'ai hâte de
tourner dans les prochaines aussi je
pense mais je rigole cet homme est un
comédien de qualité on peut dire les
actions
vas-y tu es tu cap est belle la vie et
où vous avez pu le voir dans plus belle
la vie et jouer roland le rouge jeune
blake te ment les années soixante quatre
contrôle quoi c'était un très bon moi
j'ai regardé j'ai kiffé super merci
hélas prochainement je tente dans un
super film je t'aime s'était fait donc
tu parles ça te dérange pas non moi je
t'avais raison je kiffe les faits les
faits envie de vomir c'est quoi déjà
ouais je sais puisque c'est cela à oued
accord s écoule ce qu'ils font ouais
j'sais pas beaucoup dormi dix nuits mais
généralistes comme des comédiens je te
mets en effet eu voilà effet comédiens
classe donc ça marche ça ne fonctionne
plus tard dans la vie
jean temps de savourer la vie
actuellement je la croque à pleines
dents
donc du coup est donc peut-être tourné
dans la vidéo je le rappelle
actuellement la vie où tu faisais le
joggeur exactement tu sais d'ailleurs
alors oui je sais d'ailleurs tu as été
reprises comme moi pas du tout mais
c'est toi qui avais écrit texte de
marguerite long du texte il a vu la
vidéo
il a dit ok c'est nickel je prends
vraiment cet homme fort et plus
largement dans 18 grandes tours assez
mois il a plus que toi il a dû dire moi
j'suis vraiment bas mais c'était très
drôle en tout cas j'ai eu plein de bons
retours sur cette vidéo vous mettez un
maximum de pouce en l'air si vous
trouvez cet homme sympathique
voilà mettez des pouces en l'air j'adore
ça avant des boissons tabac' évidemment
qui est le snat suivant rafaelillo tout
attaché donc rafael et lio elle est
chanteuse l'excellent la blague nul
qu'on perd à chaque fois depuis l'école
là où j'ai fait la blague de base ne
fait jamais ce genre de blagues ne
prenez pas exemple sur moi
le volcan est heureux que quand on est
en train de kif et sarah s'il vous dit
pas son plaisir
il est en train de prendre une dose de
quitte mon pote
bon allez donc il faut qu'on trouve
maintenant 3e troisième objet troisième
chose animal individus personnages
ajoutés dans le décor et puis on va le
mettre comme ça ça fera un petit mur
interactif avec les abonnés c'était le
but un dragon
j'ai vu un dragon vous avez que des
trucs vous a vécu des trucs extrêmement
compliqué à faire c'est vraiment chaud
mettre un dragon on veut un céleri alors
le gars veut un céleri
[Musique]
peut-être qu'on peut déjà partir sur un
projet de légumes on sait pas lequel
mais moi ce sera d'être un petit peu
moins - tu es gay que le le dragon mais
on pourra faire sur un céleri c'est un
projet on a un arc-en-ciel pas mal c'est
mignon proposer quelque chose
ouais t'as le droit et ce qui pourrait
faire le portrait de donald trump est ce
que tu veux dans l'état c'est un mur
anti donald trump on peut pas là est-ce
que la suspense à moi qui ai une petite
boutade en plus un donald trump qui fait
un truc chelou 40 des sénateurs de
gauche par donald trump qui a peut-être
un animal dessiner un avis avant d'être
un trop loin trop trop techniques trop
loin bon allez je veux un dernier elodie
nous propose un chat très bonne
proposition
un chasse et voilà c'est la fois simple
et efficace fait le chat va tellement
vite j'ai du mal à de voir un ours assez
bien c'est un ours bon allez on prend ça
est un champignon au qui retient
champignons ours licorne chat dauphin
tous les animaux de la forêt même si les
dauphins sont pas dans la forêt merci à
tous je crois que je vais acheter ce je
vais raccrocher ce live sur 7 sur 7
ténor me remarque arbres ou des dauphins
merci de nous avoir suivis mais t'es
plein temps plein deux pouces en l'air
svp c'est cool et moi je tourne une
nouvelle vidéo dans ce décor a priori
demain si tout se passe bien si j'ai
toujours envie et ça va clairement être
cool j'espère à bientôt
on n'ira pas salut c'est à tout le monde